via bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
merci de nous rejoindre pour ceux qui
sont en distance yale et merci pour le
public d'être avec nous pour ce premier
grand débat du samedi de notre salon les
visionnaires de saint quentin en
yvelines le salon du livre et c'est un
grand honneur pour moi un grand plaisir
d'accueillir nos trois invités parce
qu'ils sont à la fois prestigieux et
parce que nous avons également de grands
sportifs avec nous tout d'abord je veux
bien venu isabelle queval donc un
bienvenue nicolet gutiérrez bienvenue
guillaume martin alors on ad'autres nos
invités qui ont autant de mérite que
nous mais peut-être beaucoup plus parce
qu'ils viennent de faire on me l'a dit
le tour de piste il vient de faire le
baptême de piste donc félicitations
parce qu'il faut avoir du courage
guillaume a été dispensée par ce qu'il a
l'habitude mais je crois que lui la puce
d'habitude à voir surtout des freins sur
son vélo ce qui n'est pas le cas de faux
de nos vélos de piste voit la bienvenue
alors isabelle queval on va vous
présenter vous êtes ici pour un livre
qui s'appelle le sport le diable au
corps aux éditions robert laffont alors
vous avez une carrière exceptionnelle
tout d'abord une première carrière de
tenniswoman de haut niveau vous avez
quitté les courts ensuite pour la
philosophie ce qui est assez inhabituel
globalement vous enseignez à evreux tout
en vous occupant de la formation des
futurs professeurs d'éducation physique
à ce stade de rouen comme l'on dit vous
avez d'ailleurs rédigé une thèse sur le
dépassement de soi vous êtes agrégé de
philosophie docteur en sciences de
l'éducation les titulaires d'un diplôme
d'état approfondi le célèbre dea qu'on
en vit tous en philosophie politique et
juridique vous êtes maître de
conférences université paris descartes
et cherche vous y êtes plus vous avez
été donc maître de conférences à
l'université paris descartes et vous
avez été où vous êtes encore je ne sais
plus du coup chercheuse au centre de
recherche sens éthique et société voilà
si vous étiez avant et vous étiez
associés où vous êtes toujours au centre
edgar morin dans l'équipe corps
individus et sociétés et donc c'est
pourquoi vous êtes là puisque vos
recherches portent sur le corps ses
représentations et les nouvelles
technologies qui sont appliquées c'est
le coeur de notre débat d'aujourd'hui
nicolas gouttière est ce vous avez
récemment et publié écrit au mont mclean
us enquête sur l'avenir de l'homme
augmenté par la machine aux éditions
vuibert alors vous êtes né à bogota en
colombie
raison pour laquelle vous êtes passionné
de vélo d'après ce que j'ai compris tout
à l'heure évidemment vous êtes avec nous
en france depuis 2001 année où le génome
humain d'ailleurs en même temps on a été
enfin dévoilé vous êtes passionné
d'ailleurs par sa découverte majeure ce
qui vous a amené à entamer des études de
biologie cellulaire et de génétique à
bordeaux qui a été suivie couronné d'un
doctorat vous étudiez le lien entre la
génétique et le métabolisme après ce
doctorat vous êtes allés étudier les
maladies métaboliques aux états unis
entre autres en ce qui concerne
l'adaptation des amérindiens à
l'altitude dans les andes colombiennes
vous êtes de retour en france après un
périple de plus de 10 ans dans le monde
de la recherche vous êtes reconverti au
journalisme scientifique à l'école
supérieure de journalisme de lille et
depuis vous nous aider au quotidien
j'allais dire à décrypter la recherche
biomédicale et à démêler le vrai du faux
dans l'actualité scientifique alors
qu'ils ont martin je ne sais pas si on
doit vous présenter parce que vous êtes
tellement connu et on attend tellement
de vous cette année encore pour le tour
de france vous êtes sous pression si
vous êtes der paris vous êtes donc un
très grand coureur cycliste français
vous êtes membre de la célèbre équipe
cofidis vous avez nommé notamment été
meilleur grimpeur du tour d'espagne en
2020 et vous avez obtenu une très très
belle huitième place dans un tour de
france particulier celui de l'année 2021
vous êtes également l'auteur de trois
ouvrages traitant de philosophie et de
son application aux sports et c'est donc
également à ce titre que nous vous
accueillons aujourd'hui alors nous vous
accueillons tous les trois pour vous
parler d' hygiène de vie pour parler de
passion du record face aux core dit
augmenter un petit peu parlé du
transhumanisme en effet un avenir
prophétique s'annonce du mois on nous
l'annoncent comme tel on nous dit qu'on
pourra bientôt concevoir une jambes
mécatroniques des yeux bioniques voire
freiner le vieillissement ce très très
intéressante que moi ça m'intéresse mais
si tous nos organes sont
interchangeables la question qui se pose
c'est quid de la question notre réelle
identité face au corps augmente et
justement que deviendra la compétition
sportive et si le microcosme du cyclisme
du reste avait une leçon de vie à nous
les quais alors c'est d'autant plus
prégnant que nous sommes ici au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que vous savez
que saint quentin en yvelines
accueillera quatre épreuves des jeux
olympiques en 2024 donc on est au coeur
du sujet et nous allions dans ce lieu la
culture et le sport alors je vais
commencer par une question pour vous
trois questions très très générique en
effet
souviens quand j'étais plus jeune on
avait la télévision une série qui
s'appelle l'homme qui valait trois
milliards on n'a eu dé on a eu des
marvel comme iron man on a connu super
jaimie à l'époque robocop ternie ma
terminator et la première question je
voulais vous poser isabelle queval
est-ce que vous pensez que aujourd'hui
ses personnages pourraient prendre
réalité ce qu'on est capable de les
créer
alors il ya des éléments qui s'ancre
dans une réalité le fait est qu'il ya
des sportifs avec des prothèses qui font
des performances étonnantes qui un jour
sans doute battront les records des de
leurs homologues valides comme ça a déjà
presque était le cas dans certaines
circonstances on pense à oscar pistorius
par exemple et à sa course du 400 m
notamment à londres où il avait eu
médailles à la fois chez les valides et
chez les sportifs handicapés
paralympiques
et puis en même temps il ya une part de
fantasme très très important puisque on
est effectivement dans une projection
vers des robocop du sport qui n'existe
pas et qui même aux yeux des médecins
paraissent quand même assez
difficilement réalisable néanmoins les
questions sont posées ce sont les
questions de l'hybridation du corps avec
la machine avec la prothèse avec la
chimie aussi avec la pharmacologie qui
permet d'augmenter la performance ce
sont les questions des limites du corps
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on appelle un
corps naturel et à partir du moment de
quel moment il ne l'est plus ça ce sont
des questions réelles qui amène les tic
à s'interroger sur le futur du sport
voilà parce que et j'en termine le sport
est la seule activité sociale sport de
haut niveau bien évidemment est la seule
activité sociale où il n'ya pas de
régulation dans la recherche de la
performance extrême voilà la régulation
elle se fait au travers on va dire des
lois du sport de la lutte antidopage
mais il n'y a pas de on va dire de
d'autorégulation dans la recherche
continue de la performance donc ça nous
indique aussi des directions
intéressante à questionner merci pour
ces compléments d'informations owni
collègues au tir est même question
est-ce que vous pensez que iron man va
bientôt voler dans le ciel de saint
quentin en yvelines mais précisément
c'était ça le but de ce livre enquête
c'était de savoir où s'arrêter qu'est-ce
qui était fantasmes et qu'est-ce qui
était réalité c'est à dire qu est-ce que
vraiment on pourrait faire un peu de
temps ou disons dans dix vingt ans et
qu'est-ce qui ne n'est pas possible on
n'est pas envisageable aujourd'hui par
rapport aux épaules à l'état des
recherches et donc aujourd'hui et pour
cela j'ai parlé avec une trentaine
d'experts du monde entier qui
m'ont ils ont révélé la réelle situation
aujourd'hui des recherches par rapport à
celles qu'on ne peut faire aujourd'hui
du coup par rapport à ce qu'on peut
envisager d'ici 25 ans temps
des possibilités commun robocop sont
très peu probable par contre on pourra
et on le fait déjà et
réparer le corps humain c'est-à-dire on
on est en train de créer beaucoup de
technologies qui peuvent beaucoup aider
les personnes handicapées et là il ya un
vrai avenir donc pas autant dans l'eau
l'amélioration de l'être humain mais
plutôt dans la
donner à l'être humain la chance d'être
en bonne santé pendant plus de temps
merci alors guillaume même question est
ce que dans le vélo on verra bientôt des
super jaimie capable de dépasser tout le
peloton et dans la montagne de gagner
tous les cols
je sais pas je suis pas devin mais par
contre je pense qu'en tout cas le sport
et le sportif a toujours et toujours en
quête effectivement de moyens de
se dépasser de dépasser les autres
surtout fait donc de trouver de nouveaux
outils pour être pour être meilleur et
donc il ya le développement de
soit l'entraînement mais il ya aussi
des développements matériels ou
technologique compensant en natation par
exemple à ces combinaisons là je crois
en polyuréthane qui ont permis de
l'améliorer les records mais dans le
vélo ça a été avant cela dans les années
80 bernard hinault qui
qui inventent les pédales automatiques
qui finalement font qu'on peut faire
vraiment corps avec sa machine est et
retransmettre au mieux la puissance
ensuite on a vu des vélos futuriste pour
le contre la montre notamment se
développer avec des positions très très
particulière des vélos qu'on vraiment
qu'on voit plus aujourd'hui et je pense
que c'est effectivement à des intérêts
du sport que d'aller explorer comme ça
de nouvelles voix parce que c'est il ya
eu un côté recherche dans le sport est
ensuite eu c'est aux instances je pense
internationale de se positionner par
rapport à ça et de décider si on
autorise ou interdit certaines choses
les les vélos dont on voyait certains
des vélos vraiment dans des positions
très très profilé où les coureurs
effectivement ressembler à des à des
superman en tout cas parce que c'était
la position de l'oeuvre poussé à
l'extrême vraiment le coureur était tout
droit on peut aller il pédalé de sorte à
avoir le moins de résistance à l'air
possible ça ça a été interdit parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte évidemment
qu'il y avait des dangers derrière donc
je pense que la question qui
se pose derrière c'est aussi ce qu'ont
autoriser ce qu'on interdit mais la
question de la
règle c'est elle qui
vient à l'imiter finalement tout ça on
sera on pourra toujours être dans leur
recherche de nouveaux outils mais à un
moment donné aussi le principe du sport
c'est que c'est encadré par des parts
des règles et qu'on les respecte bien
sûr alors justement isabelle queval très
belles transitions vous dites dans votre
livre que jouer pour un sportif se veut
être compris comme jouer avec les règles
ou la règle de son sport et qu'à ce
moment là on peut même aller jusqu'à
pourquoi pas tes ces nouvelles
substances de nouvelles nouveaux
médicaments vous dit également que c'est
une manière de jouer avec la règle ne
craignez-vous pas un si justement de
valider l'idée même du dopage dans le
sport non je ne valide pas du tout
simplement je dis que dans le sport de
haut niveau le principe est d'être à
l'extrême dans tous les paramètres
c'est-à-dire les matériels les matériaux
les sciences médicales de l'entraînement
la gestuelle la médecine la psychologie
la diététique etc on est toujours à
l'extrême c'est ce qui est intéressant
dans l'étude du sport de haut niveau
c'est d'avoir une sorte d'éprouvettes du
social dans laquelle on peut percevoir
certaines tendances de la société alors
eu égard aux substances dopantes eu
égard à la technicisation du corps avec
les prothèses par exemple etc donc ça
c'est effectivement la question qui est
intéressant et comme on est à l'extrême
et bien le sportif de haut niveau par
définition il est toujours à la limite
on voit bien dans tous les jeux alors
les jeux des clips les jeux de balle on
voit bien qu'il ya toujours une limite
qui est voilà qui est approché qui est
effleuré la limite du hors-jeu la limite
de la ligne au tennis etc donc c'est le
principe même d'être à la limite sinon
on n'est pas au niveau si quelqu'un peut
encore être plus proche de la limite que
soit c'est que soi même on n'est pas au
très haut niveau donc le très haut
niveau c'est un jeu avec la limite et
donc qui a effectivement cette tentation
parfois de franchir la ligne et c'est le
on va dire le principe du sport de poser
des règles qui sont toujours
conventionnelle c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent être aussi démenti à un moment
donné qui pose la règle entre le permis
et le défendu
alors du coup ça l'amène à vous poser
une question qu'est ce que pour vous
d'être un sportif de haut niveau
aujourd'hui en quelques mots c'est très
très dur a résumé mais si on est à la
limite de la règle on est un sportif de
haut niveau non mais quand on est un
sportif de haut niveau on est à la
limite on va dire de tous les paramètres
pas simplement des règles de l'ensemble
des paramètres c'est-à-dire le maximum
d'entraînement le maximum de potentiel
aussi le maximum de technicité les
matériaux les plus performants et
l'utilisation maximale des règles et des
et des possibilités mais séparés par les
règles ça dépend des ça dépend des
sports bien sûr on le voit par exemple
en natation il ya tout un tas de règles
maintenant qui encadre la coulée de
départ on a vu que là on a un nageur
français qui était un tout petit peu
trop sur le dos lors de son départ en
crawl et bien il a été disqualifié voilà
donc c'est ça ce jeu avec la règle c'est
comment gagner quelques quelques
centièmes quelques millièmes tout en
restant dans la loi mais en essayant de
voir ce qu'on pourrait encore gagner
pour pour s'améliorer
je note également que différentes études
je pense par exemple à celle de
l'institut de recherche biomédicale et
d'épidémiologie du sport conclut que
nous allons bientôt atteint des limites
dit indépassable dans les performances
sportives est ce que pour vous cela vous
sans perdre et en platine en oubliant
contrat les records continueront ils à
être dépassé dans le futur alors moi je
pense que d'abord ce sont des études qui
ne porte que des sur des sports dits
physiologique c'est à dire et comme
assez peu de matériel assez peu d'engins
de type course à pied natation etc et
puis ce serait réduire le sport de haut
niveau à n'être que de la physiologie ça
n'est évidemment pas le cas puisque le
sport de haut niveau c'est une activité
technique le sport d'ailleurs ce une
activité technique dès le début par
essence c'est à dire que toute
l'histoire du sport c'est une histoire
deux techniques du sport et par
conséquent comme
le disait très bien tout à l'heure
guillaume est bien au fur et à mesure
des années des choses sont tentés cette
lorsqu'elles sont autorisés on améliore
les records et puis parfois on
s'aperçoit comme avec les combinaisons
de natation c'est allé trop loin puisque
les nageurs n'avaient même plus besoin
de faire de battements de pieds pour
flotter voilà donc là on se dit non on
est en train de dénaturer la natation
d'en faire autre chose et on revient en
arrière mais c'est ça l'histoire du
sport et donc au cours de l'histoire des
techniques on a vu des sauteurs en
hauteur essayez des chaussures à
ressorts on a vu des nageurs se gonfler
le ventre de gaz on a vu tout un tas de
guidon de siège et s'est profilée dont
certains ont été autorisés et puis
d'autres voilà on a vu des raquettes de
tennis avec des doubles cordages c'est
ça c'est l'innovation et cette
innovation là on peut pas dire qu'elle
va s'arrêter et par conséquent voit
encore des records du monde qui sont
battus peut-être moins qu'avant mais
quand même régulièrement voilà ce que
vous êtes ici dans un territoire
d'innovation nous sommes très attentifs
justement à toutes ces innovations
technologiques et à leurs applications
quand elle vient du sport ensuite dans
le monde dans les banques quotidien j'ai
dit nicolas gutiérrez est ce que on peut
raisonnablement vouloir éradiquer les
maladies parce que c'est un des sujets
sur lequel vous intervenez beaucoup est
ce que vivre mieux et plus longtemps au
risque de jouer aux apprentis sorciers
en bousculant à jamais notre révolution
est envisageable
et alors ça c'est une grande discussion
qu'on doit faire en tant que société
parce que il ya beaucoup d'enjeux là
dedans c'est à dire la technologie et la
science peuvent permettre en effet de
deux de réparer
beaucoup l'être humain le corps humain
est de plus en plus on pourra le faire
il ya à peine deux mois on a implanté le
premier coeur de cochon dans un être
humain et
et là personne n'a survécu pendant deux
mois grâce à son coeur de cochon c'est
la première c'est c'était une première
c'est la première fois qu'on a fait ça
pour sauver la vie de quelqu'un ça a
marché pas longtemps mais ça a ouvert
une porte vers
imaginons une
une culture en masse des cochons pour
avoir nous des organes donc est-ce qu'on
est d'accord avec ça ou pas jusqu'où on
est d'accord ou pas pour ça parce qu'un
effet ils ont que la science peut aller
très loin après c'est à nous en tant que
société de savoir jusqu'où on peut aller
jusque on doit aller etc des discussions
qui doivent se faire un amant avant que
cela arrive alors du coup nicolas
gutiérrez à ce que demain nous serons
tous des cyborgs et béganne a déjà pas
mal parmi nous après c'est pas du tout
les cyborgs comme on imagine ses
présidences et par vaux coop c'est pas
un terminator c'est il ya des cyborgs
qui ont des implants qu'ils permettent
de mieux entendre des cyborgs qui ont
des bras mécaniques qui du coup mais ils
ont réparé leur corps après avoir perdu
le roi à cause d'un accident ou autre
chose et et il y aura de plus en plus de
ces gens là après la plupart d'entre eux
ça serra pour
réparer c'est à dire pour arriver disons
est ce qu'on considère la normalité
aujourd'hui mais pas pour améliorer là
c'est une autre question qui se pose
mais ça commence la question se pose pas
remplies ya haineux avec le squelette
qui a été créé pour les personnes nées
sportifs qui font du ski pour soutenir
les jeunes ou c'est à dire pourquoi ils
font comme ça que ça soit le x2 québec
qui prennent la pression est pas le
genou donc après ça c'est rare qu'on
faisait et monsieur martin de haut
régulateur de dire si on laissait raoult
pas utiliser ça lors des compétitions
etc disons qu on peut aller très loin
dans l'évolution de la technologie et de
la technique après c'est aux sociétés de
savoir jusqu'où on doit on veut arriver
alors on parle beaucoup du corps depuis
tout à l'heure mais l'élément essentiel
qui le guide si le cerveau et dans votre
livre au moma qu'ils n'eussent nous
parler du cerveau 2.0 alors qu'est ce
que vous nous en dire qu'est ce que
c'est pour vous le cerveau justement 2.0
mais beaucoup de personnes fantasmes
avec l'invité de
fusionner notre cerveau à quelque chose
des plus grands à un ordinateur connecté
à internet et donc du cookie imaginons
je veux savoir en quelle année ce
vélodrome a été fait
mon cerveau se connecte rapidement sur
wikipédia est le sien quelques secondes
et où que comme ça imaginons du coup la
mémoire que j'aurais et les infinies
parce que j'ai pas besoin de mémoire je
peux tout savoir et je peux me connecter
avec n'importe qui qui soit aussi
connecté n'a pas besoin de parler on
puisse communiquer comme ça c'est un
fantasme c'est un fantasme geek qui est
comment dire qui est un fantasme ancré
dans l'air et dans la réalité il y à des
implants cybernétiques sur lequel on
travaille notamment de novalink et de
l'entreprise delaune masque qui
travaille sur un plan libe son idée à
lui ces deux arrivées à connecter le
cerveau humain à l'intelligence
artificielle après en vrai c'est un plan
vont être très utile pour lutter contre
les handicaps pour lutter pendant qu'ils
contrôlent parkinson alzheimer pour ça
ça va beaucoup servir après pour nous
connecter à l'intelligence artificielle
à des ordinateurs etc
c'est beaucoup moins probable dans le
sens que déjà c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et aussi si on y arrive et les
questions éthiques que ça pose son
gigantesque parce qu'imaginez que mon
cerveau connecté à internet
on sent que ça veut dire que on ne
pourrait rentrer dans mon cerveau qu'on
montre comment rendre aujourd'hui dans
un ordinateur et c'est pire encore on ne
pourrait
faire rentrer une idée dans ma tête
j'aurais l'impression que c'est moi qui
a eu l'idée je ne pourrais pas savoir
quelles idées viennent d'ailleurs et
donc du coup
où je m'arrête mois où commencent les
autres mon individualité et les n'existe
plus et
donc c'est que c'est un sujet qui pose
énormément de questions heureusement il
ya beaucoup de bioéthicien qui travaille
précisément dès aujourd'hui sur ces
questions là et c'est très intéressant
ce qu'ils ont à dire alors est ce que
vous diriez pas ce qu on a l'air très
avancé dans ses différents points
scientifique on a l'impression que le
transhumanisme est pour demain alors est
ce qu'il est pour demain ce qu'il est
déjà là ce qu'il ya autour de nous et ce
que nous sommes déjà des transhumain
sans nous en rendre compte ça dépend ce
qu'on l'entende parts un suma l'isthme
c'est à dire on est déjà amélioré par
rapport à l'être humain il ya cinq
siècles je porte des lunettes il ya cinq
siècles je ne verrai pas aussi bien que
je vois aujourd'hui ça c'est grâce à la
technologie
aujourd'hui je suis vacciné donc je suis
protégé contre plein de maladies grâce à
la technologie j'ai déjà on est déjà
mieux qu'on était avant grâce à la
technologie après
c'est pas
comment dire tout ça c'est pour me
permettre de mieux vivre en marge des
disons que d'avoir une pire meilleure
santé pendant plus de temps c'est ça le
l'idéal après et c'est ça le problème
l'idéal transhumanistes mais plutôt 2
allée aux déçus au délà de créer un
autre être humain un précisément un homo
mcinnis un humain qui sert à plus forts
plus rapides plus intelligent plus
plus long jamais du coup éternelle et
c'est là où ça pose problème est ce que
on veut en tant que société aller vers
ça parce que imaginons si on est tous
éternel déjà ce que c'est possible la
terre pourra tenir autant de demandes ne
qui meurt pas après c'est sûr que c'est
pas possible parce que ça serait trop
cher donc il y aurait sortent seulement
certains qui auraient accès d'autres non
on pose beaucoup de questions isabelle
vous lire ajouter quelque chose vraie
passion le problème du transit humanisme
c'est que justement c'est pas simplement
la question de l'amélioration de
l'humanité c'est l'idée d'une post
humanité et là on est en rupture franche
avec une idéologie du progrès dans
laquelle on vit et qu'on a hérité
la philosophie des lumières c'est à dire
du xviiie siècle on vit encore sur cette
lancée là or le transhumanisme lui
projette une post humanité à plusieurs
vitesses c'est à dire qu'effectivement
la question du coût se posera pour
l'accès à toutes ces technologies aient
cessé ces transformations techniques il
y aura toute une part de l'humanité
qu'il n'y aura pas accès donc il y aura
effectivement une humanité à plusieurs
vitesses avec des une sorte de sous
humanité le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se projette dans
cette idéologie la perçoivent l'humanité
entre guillemets naturel d'aujourd'hui
comme la soude humanité de demain c'est
à dire que le naturel d'aujourd'hui qui
ne sera pas augmentée demain finalement
pâtira de sa de sa naturalité par
rapport à la technique voilà
alors ça nous amène tout ça un petit peu
à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
applicatifs c'est c'est le peloton le
peloton cycliste dans lequel on va
retrouver peut-être tous étrange humain
qui existent peut-être déjà ils sont
autour de nous tous et ses nouvelles
technologies aussi alors la société du
peloton vous avez que vous avez écrit
guillaume martin ne serait ce pas après
tout un livre iconoclaste sur la feature
la figure de l'athlète sur le sport en
général est en fait la vraie question
qui se pose c'est que vaut pour le
cyclisme l'individualité par rapport au
collectif
oui effectivement c'est le sujet de mon
livre alors le sujet de mon le coeur de
mon livre n'est pas forcément le
transhumanisme alors on est un peu sur
un autre sujet mais
mais c'est effectivement la question du
lien entre individuel et
et collectifs et comment
je pense que c'est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe tous comment
ce paradoxe qui est qu' on ne peut pas
vivre enfin les autres nous insupporte
souvent dans un peloton c'est le cas
quand on échapper le peloton nous
insupporte parce que nous rattrape
souvent à trois kilomètres de la ligne
hé hé
et c'est affreux parce qu'on essaye de
résister on jette toutes ses forces dans
la bataille on sait que c'est inexorable
que les équipes de sprinteurs sont
organisés avons rentré donc on rêve d'un
monde sans peloton de la même manière
que dans la vie de tous les jours on
rêve d'une de
parfois de partir s'exiler sur une île
déserte et puis en même temps quand on
est cycliste on raisonne un petit peu et
puis très vite on se dit qu une course
cycliste sans peloton ça n'a plus de
sens ça n'existe plus il ya plus de
victoires possibles sans concurrent
froides à vaincre sans péril on triomphe
sans gloire on a besoin d'eux de l'autre
comme d'une sorte de témoin de son
individualité propre et et je pense que
évidemment dans la vie de tous les jours
il n'ya pas d'existence possible sans
coexistence donc c'est ce ce lien
compliquées entre l'individuel et le
collectif que j'ai essayé de de
travailler dans ce livre
vous dites d'ailleurs qu'on ne peut pas
vivre sans peloton et donc est ce que
vous pensez que l'homme demeure un
animal indéfectiblement sociale ou bien
ce que vous pensez malgré tout qu'ils
seraient capables de vivre seul
non je pense que évidemment que que
l'homme est un animal politique sociale
que
mémé le paradoxe et qui vit très mal
avec ça c'est que il a
bien vu là
récemment avec ces histoires de decaux
vite ça le le vivre ensemble les règles
du vivre ensemble
sont pas des règles justement flou va on
revient à la question de la règle
justement et des débats éthiques qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir et qu'on devra
avoir
fait c'est pas facile c'est ça le
problème c'est que justement c'est pas
facile de trancher et et
et de décider de
ce que doit être un avenir taux commun
déjà qui décide en vertu de quoi pour
pour qui
est ce que diplôme
universitaire permet de décider sur des
réponses d'orientation sociétale
voilà est-ce que c'est un fonctionnement
totalement démocratique il doit choisir
mais là aussi il ya des pans ce cas les
problèmes dans le système démocratique
et parfois on a vu par le passé que le
peuple a pu faire des des erreurs donc
donc tout ça c'est des sujets compliqués
c'est le
effectué on revient comment comment
fixer la limite pour rebondir sur ce qui
était dit tout à l'heure il y à il ya la
question de la de la règle eu
que des instances en charge et a
posteriori d'appliquer mais en même
temps je pense qu'on peut pas se limiter
au fait de se reposer sur sur des
instances extérieures je pense qu'aussi
soi même en tant qu'individu alité on a
une responsabilité
moi en tant que coureur en tout cas je
me limite pas
à ce qui est autorisé interdit je pense
qu'il ya vraiment des
ce serait trop facile en fait parce
qu'on se voit bien là on a vu que dans
le peloton l'an dernier ceux parmi vous
qui sont au fait un peu de l'actualité
cycliste il ya eu dans une équipe des
perquisitions et on n'a vu qu'une équipe
utilisé des médicaments pour soigner la
sclérose en plaques et les détourner à
des fins d'amélioration des performances
c'était
c'était pas interdit c'était un produit
qui n'était pas sur la liste des
produits dopants mais là je pense qu'à
ce moment là on va en faire appel à son
éthique personnelle où doit se
construire moi en tout cas c'est ce que
je fais et se construire sa propre
éthique et se dire non là on est on
reste dans le cadre de la limite de ce
qui est autorisé
mais quand même on s'est interdit parce
qu'il ya il ya quand même une question
un peu de
de décence et donc mais mais mais c'est
toujours en fait des questions
compliquées des questions qu'ils se
rétablissent au cas par cas je pense
c'est pour ça que moi je plaide pour
aussi une une responsabilisation de
chacun de l'individu et ne pas s'en
remettre totalement justement au groupe
hop loto ou à une entité
supérieure qui qui viendrait de manière
verticale nous dire quoi faire ou ce
qu'il est bon de faire
vous dites justement dans certains de
vos interviews et j'ouvre les guillemets
parce que c'est vous qui nous l'avait
dit cette idée du tous dopés c'est
quelque chose que j'avais un peu
intériorisé malgré moi des débuts de ma
carrière selon vous le cyclisme se
serait-il donc destinés qu'à être le
théâtre artificiel où seule la tromperie
tiendrait le premier rôle
ça change de passionnés de cyclisme
d'accord je me rappelle plus de cette
interview avoir dit ça comme ça mais ça
j'ai travaillé je travaille et je n'en
doute pas
en tout cas non mais c'est sûr que dans
le cyclisme évidemment compatit
2 du passé du cyclisme est notamment des
années 90 des années armstrong en fin
d'une époque où festina 81,18 j'avais 5
ans quoi
le cyclisme a évolué depuis mais malgré
tout c'est vrai que on entend toujours
des réflexions et je pense que inscrits
dans l'imaginaire collectif il ya
cyclisme égale dopage donc ça évidemment
quand on en pâtit il ya tout un sujet
aussi sur
comment quel argument mettre en avant
quand on est coureur pour pour se
justifier est-ce qu'il faut se justifier
aussi
si comme argument je dis que je me fais
contrôler je sais pas 20 25 fois par an
en fait c'était l'argument qu'employé
armstrong
donc cet argument il est il est parce qu
il est pas recevable parce que lui tous
et à tous et des tests antidopage était
négatif donc donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
compliqué aussi de comment réussir à
ceux à se justifier alors nous avait dit
également et ça c'est intéressant par
rapport au rôle du du cycliste au sein
du peloton que les cyclistes ce
fonctionnaire ''serait peut-être un
petit peu trop avec des équipiers qui
met totalement de côté leurs ambitions
personnelles et on se retrouve avec une
course d'une trentaine de coureurs
pouvant seulement prétendre à la
victoire je pense que 30 c'est même
beaucoup j'ai besoin c'est beaucoup
moins alors qu'on est il est ce que tous
les coureurs ont ils vraiment les mêmes
chances de briller et du coup
peuvent-ils encore on encore ont-ils une
chance de se dépasser individuellement
au sein du peloton
oui j'ai employé le mot ce
fonctionnarisé ce fonctionnaire et un
peu trop gentil pour les actionnaires ma
compagne
fonctionnaires en plus alors
chacun roule pas déterminées dont ils ne
peuvent pas sortir et que le bon coureur
est celui qui va être le bon gars
équipiers qui du coup n'ont fait
peut-être jamais la chance de briller
alors qu'il a peut-être pardon guillaume
les mêmes capacités que le que le leader
c'est sûr qu'à une vraie organisation
hiérarchique dans un dans un peloton et
d'ailleurs c'est c'est ça qui permet
aussi aujourd'hui pour en revenir à la
question de l'amélioration des
performances ou des temps de monter ça
c'était une autre facette de
l'amélioration des performances et que
quand il ya quarante cinquante ans les
grosso modo les coureurs monter les cols
un peu chacun de leur côté alors que
maintenant pour les sprints il ya des
trains mais dans l'école aussi il ya des
trains donc être plein d'effets
d'aérodynamisme y compris dans l'école
qui fait qu'on peut aller plus vite et
qu'on peut aller aujourd'hui plus vite
de manière saine que dans les années 90
par exemple en étant dopé
donc donc oui il ya une organisation
hiérarchique après j'entends ce que vous
voulez dire et c'est vrai que je peux le
vivre il ya une telle organisation
hiérarchique dans les équipes je pense à
l'image de la société que chacun revient
à 6 pers spécialisée dans son domaine et
les leaders ne sont plus bons qu'à
rester dans la roue leurs coéquipiers
jusqu'au 5 derniers kilomètres et ne
maîtrise plus vrai que moi j'ai plutôt
leader de mon équipe si jamais un jour
je dois aller chercher des bidons à la
voiture faire le travail d'un d'un
équipier ben je suis pas très habile
pour le faire
et à linverse un coéquipier qui
un jour se retrouvent en situation de
gagner une course il n'a pas l'habitude
de le faire donc parfois il peut
peut-être
paniqué et
ça peut être un peu triste aussi en ce
sens que
c'est pas forcément l'essence du sport
ou en tout cas moi quand j'ai commencé
le vélo c'est évidemment parce ça que je
je voyais que je vivais je prenais la
course le départ d'une course pour pour
simplement pour pour gagner pour faire
le meilleur résultat possible et est
maintenant je dirais que vides ouais
c'est sans doute un peu plus à un métier
il ya moi cette fraîcheur des débuts
mais en même temps on a retrouvé il ya
plein de choses passionnantes aussi dans
ce côté stratégique il ya des lectures
de course quand on connaît un peu toute
la stratégie des tactiques derrière qui
sont qui sont ce qu'ils sont
passionnantes de savoir comment
justement c'est des échecs en fait de
savoir comment utiliser les équipiers à
quel moment donc
je serai nuancée par rapport à cette
cette question à la fois c'est un peu
triste parce qu'effectivement on n'a que
que oui 20 30 coureurs qui réellement se
joue la victoire sur un peloton de 181
mais en même temps
en même temps il ya toute une part
tratégie qu'effectivement qui est
intéressante
isabelle queval je change un petit
interrupteur j'essaie de surprendre
aux auteurs aujourd'hui dans votre livre
un petit peu j'ai noté un centre de
phrases comme j'ai fait avec guillaume
un instant vous nous dit également que
la vie bonne c'est la vie longue et que
pour avoir cette longue vie et bien le
soutien à un certain prix alors ma
question c'est est-ce que pour vous
quelques par le médecin ne remplacerai
t-il pas finalement le philosophe
alors oui ce que je dis c'est qu'on vit
une injonction
collective et quotidienne à la santé et
à la meilleure santé possible qui met
quand même une pression sur sûrs chacun
puisqu'il ya eu quand même aussi une
part de culpabilisation dans le sens où
si je ne respecte pas toutes ces
prescriptions donc ne pas fumer ne pas
boire trop d'alcool ne pas trop manger
bien manger et c'est finalement je
risque de tomber malade je dirais de ma
faute voilà et là il ya un poids qui
pèse sur la responsabilité de chacun de
sa santé alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on projette la vie de bonnes
notions philosophiques très très
ancienne on la voit plutôt comme la vie
longue et la plus longue possible voilà
donc on est tous embarqués dans une
projection alors en plus dans une
société
avancée comme on dit dans laquelle
l'espérance de vie est quand même assez
reculée puisqu'à autour de 80 ans pour
les hommes comme pour les femmes donc on
est tous embarqués dans cette projection
de notre existence où finalement vise la
santé la meilleure possible plus
longtemps possible vivre vieux et dans
un corps le plus confortable possible
voilà qui est finalement impose une
sorte de méticulosité quotidienne dans
l'entretien de soi qui voilà qui ne
laisse pas de répit c'est à dire que on
est on est dans le le paradigme d'un
core capital voilà capital corp au core
capital on le voit bien d'ailleurs quand
on quand on cherche à obtenir un prêt
auprès d'une banque ou bien à souscrire
une police d'assurance on a tout un
questionnaire médical qui nous fait bien
comprendre qu'on est dans une relation
avec notre corps qui est
celle d'un d'une relation avec un
capital et donc ce capital il faut
l'entretenir
alors on complément nicolas gutiérrez
toujours dans votre livre et ça rebondit
sur ce que ce qu'isabelle vient de dire
nous parle également vous de la mort et
surtout de la mort du vieillissement
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire puisque vous pensez apparemment
qu'on sera très rapidement capables de
vivre 150 ou 200 ans mais la vraie
question c'est est ce qu'on le pourra en
bonne santé parce qu'en fait on veut
vivre vieux mais en bonne santé
alors le court at on
annoncé liu des bonnes nouvelles donc ça
c'est
donc j'ai parlé avec plusieurs experts
sur ça leurs réponses en gros c'est
aujourd'hui je dirais non mais peut-être
que je me trompe c'est à dire
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'état des
recherches etc ça paraît impossible mais
le problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas
prévoir les avancées scientifiques c'est
à dire
il y à des
technologies de rupture qui peuvent
arriver
sans prévenir et qui peuvent tout
changer
c'était pourtant le cas de crise perd
ses fameux 6 et ciseaux génétique qui
permet de manipuler facilement le génome
avant ça les chercheurs pouvaient
manipuler et faire des la génie
génétique mais c'était très compliqué
c'était très long et ça marchait pas
très bien là ça marche bien c'est pas
très cher c'est relativement facile du
coup beaucoup de chercheurs sont en
train de travailler avec cet outil là
maintenant pour quoi faire on peut soit
et la plupart du temps c'est pour des
expériences et terre pour savoir si une
telle mutation peut causer ou pas une
maladie et donc comme ça on peut y en a
d'autres qui plus tôt peut-être qu'avec
ça on peut améliorer le génome de
quelqu'un et donc c'est pas simple ce
qui est arrivé en 2018 avec les
étudiants qu un chercheur chinois qui à
manipuler génétiquement des bébés
avant leur naissance et que aujourd'hui
du coup à donner naissance au premier
bébé aux gènes le lui et nana qui dans
dans ce qu'ils disaient c'était pour les
protéger du sida on pense plutôt que
c'était pour essayer d'améliorer leurs
commissions leurs capacités cognitives
peu importe que ces
techniques m'ont déjà on sait pas un
vrai ce qu'il a fait on sait pas quelles
mutations et lacko 7-6 et chez ses
enfants et du coup la question se pose
aujourd'hui de comment suivre au mieux
ses enfants dans leur toute leur vie
parce que ils peuvent développer
n'importe quelle maladie on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas leur génome quelles
mutations il a aujourd'hui parce que
même les textes les techniques les mieux
développés comme chris peur elle pas
encore des erreurs contrôle pas
entièrement mêmes donc ça il ya disons
qu'il ya une première question c'est sûr
là les capacités techniques mais ensuite
une fois qu'on arrive à maîtriser ses
capacités techniques est ce que parce
qu'on peut on doit est ce que parce
qu'on peut faire sans qu'ils aient trop
de problèmes on doit le faire est ce que
on veut vraiment aller vers une société
où on puisse être de certains enfants
puissent être plus intelligent que
d'autres est-ce que du coup si tous les
ambitieux disons on le fait à tous les
enfants et tout le monde est plus
intelligent est ce que vraiment ça nous
avance
le plus probable c'est que ça sera juste
certain qu'ils seront donc du coup on
crée quasiment une humanité concert
donné à deux vitesses est ce que c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut faire
donc disons qu'il ya des il ya des ces
technologies de rupture qui peuvent
arriver à n'importe quel moment un autre
exemple c'est que ce choeur de cochon
dans le livre j'en parle c'était la
livre a été publié en octobre à ce
moment là les donc les organes et qui
cultive être content qu'on fait qu'on
fait grandir dans des animaux c'est un
rêve qu'on a beaucoup de chercheurs ont
depuis longtemps en fantasme plus tôt
mais qui marchait pas qu'ils marchaient
jamais et
c'était en octobre kazan en septembre
sept piliers un mois après première fois
que ça marche le ram de cochon a marché
ensuite trois mois après le coeur de
cochon c'était impossible de prévoir que
ça allait marcher
maintenant ça marche technologie de
rupture où ça va nous mener on ne sait
pas donc du coup là tout ça pour dire la
réponse est aujourd'hui on dirait nos
mais en vrai on ne sait pas
merci alors en conclusion je vais je
vais terminer par nos deux sportifs avec
par rapport à tout ce qu'on vienne se
dit on a vu l'évolution du corps humain
on a vu les modifications on a vu le
futur on a vu probablement notre notre
vie plus longue et du coup la question
sera pour d'autres sportifs je vais
commencer par par isabelle sk
l'éclairage de toutes ces réponses vous
dirais que le sport est toujours un
moteur de rêve pour l'être humain en
quelques mots est ce que ça nous fait
encore rêver
surtout
surtout ce qu'il faut dire c'est que il
n'y a pas qu'un seul sport il y en a
plusieurs il ya plein de manières de
faire du sport il n'ya pas que le sport
de haut niveau il ya plein de manière
aussi de jouer en faisant du sport donc
je crois qu'il faut pas se priver de à
la fois de rêver au près de l'exploit
mais aussi de rêver dans d'autres
circonstances qui sont dans la nature
par exemple dans le dépassement de soi
individuel il ya plein d'autres on va
dire plein d'autres manières de faire
mais même question guillaume est ce que
le le sport le cyclisme moi ça me fait
toujours rêver mais est ce que le sport
en général fait toujours rêver selon
vous malgré toutes ces possibilités
scientifiques de non modifiés je pense
oui et je pense que le principe du sport
c'est quand même qu'un humain est au
coeur de tout ça alors la tendance
générale sans doute va à ce qui est de
plus en plus de
de contrôle ou de sciences qui s'immisce
dans le dans les sports parce qu'on veut
maîtriser de plus en plus tous les
aspects de la performance et on est de
plus en plus précis donc
on va dire que si avant c'était 50 % 2
maîtrise de la performance par par
l'entraînement par le matériel par la
nutrition et serra et 50% de l'esa de
d'humains de taffetas aujourd'hui le
rapport
s'inverse à la faveur du côté
scientifique maîtrise qui est
aujourd'hui 95% de deux maîtrises parce
que c'est vrai que moi dans mon
quotidien tout et tout est calculé de
j'ai un programme d'entraînement qui est
vraiment extrêmement précis on je pèse
mes aliments pendant la course donc tout
est très précis les stratégies de course
mais néanmoins je vais avoir une pointe
d'optimiste pas d'optimisme par rapport
à tout ça je pense qu'il restera
toujours ses 5 % peut-être un jour ce
sera un pour cent du main au milieu de
tout ça qui
sait le oui le l'instinct du sportif au
milieu de tout ça qui à un moment donné
à son oreillette et peut décider de la
débrancher ou alors sentir qu'il faut
attaquer alors que le directeur sportif
dit que ce n'est pas le cas ou alors
qu'ils voient c'est son capteur de
puissance ces watts et qui se dit non je
me sens bien aujourd'hui je sens que je
suis capable de faire plus de watts
qu'est ce que je fais habituellement
donc de ne pas suivre ce que me dit mon
compteur et je pense que ça ça restera
toujours et finalement c'est un presque
devenir de plus en plus passionnant
parce que tous les aspects de contrôle
ça extérieurement on peut les maîtriser
mais ce qui va faire la différence avec
le l'humain la petite part d'humain au
milieu de tout ça et celle là elle va
toujours tout m'est toujours resté et
une deuxième chose par rapport à ça
je n'avais aussi des tentatives un peu
récemment la dans le palais en tout cas
dans le cyclisme pendant les années
qu'ovide 2
de compétition sur des plateformes en
ligne de course virtuelle pas si vous
avez vu ça
où ont pédalé sur des home trainer sur
des vélos d'appartement et tout on était
tous reliés à distancer et donc quand ça
c'était assez déshumanisé quand même
comme système
et la bonne nouvelle peut être pour moi
en tout cas c'est que ça n'a pas du tout
ça a été un flop ça n'a pas du tout
marché et le public n'a pas du tout
suivi les coureurs non plus d'ailleurs
et ça doit intéresser personne c'était
retransmis à la télé il ya eu des très
mauvaises audiences donc donc ça c'est
peut-être une bonne nouvelle aussi pour
le fait que le sport puisse rester
humain un peu merci merci beaucoup
guillaume martin on vous retrouve donc
sur votre stand pour votre livre la
société du peloton que j'ai avec moi
merci d'avoir répondu présent à la fois
pour le salon et pour cette interview
merci isabelle queval pour donc le sport
le diable au corps et merci d'avoir
répondu et nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage également scientifique et puis
votre expérience de tennis woman et
merci à nicolas gutierrez pour hautmont
back in us on regardera plus nos jambes
raides au pied de la même façon après
vous avoir lu et après vous avoir écouté
merci à tous les trois et puis on se
retrouve donc au salon les visionnaires
dans quelques instants merci et très
bonne journée merci à toutes et à tous
[Musique]